Okay, so now I've left the most annoying thing for last. I've gotta deal with
leap years. And my campaign to eliminate leap years has not been successful, so
we've gotta figure out a way to figure out if it's a leap year. And the rules
for leap years are pretty complicated. Let's see, what Wikipedia has to tell us
about that. This is quite interesting. You can see how accurate the solstice is
over time as the leap days go. But the great thing here is that it actually has
code. And it's not Python code but it's pretty close. But this is a very clear
way to describe the algorithm for determining whether a year is a leap year or
not. If it's divisible by 400 then it's a leap year, if it's divisible by
100 then it's not, if it was not divisible by 400, if it's divisible
by four then it's a leap year, otherwise it's not a leap year. So, let's turn that into code.
I'm going to cut and paste that, so I can see. If i was doing this
with a smaller font size or a larger screen, I could see that at the same time,
so I wouldn't have to cut and paste it. But it's a good thing to have as a comment
anyway. So all we've got to do now is turn that into Python. And I could do it
in a straightforward way. I'm going to be a little bit lazier and save some typing by doing it in one line.
Let me reconsider. I'm going to try to get this right the first time. We'll use a few more lines of code and I will follow
what Wikipedia says more carefully.
So if the year mod 400 is equal to 0, we're going
to return True. It is a leap year. If the year mod 100 is equal to 0, we're
going to return False. It's not a leap year. If the year mod 4 is equal to 0,
we're going to return True. And if not, but we don't actually need the else,
because we've been returning, we're going to return False. So let's test that.
And if I wasn't thinking this was simple, I would probably write some special
test cases, to test leap years. I'm going to just do it by hand with a few test
cases now, because I think there aren't too many difficult ones. So 2000 is
divisible by 400, so it should be a leap year. 2100 is not divisible by 400, so
should not be a leap year and 2012 should be a leap year, and 2013 should not be
a leap year. So I think I'm fairly confident that I got that right. So now,
we're going to try to put that into daysInMonths. We need to change the case
for daysInMonth when the month is February. Now we need to check the year, and
if it's a leap year, we return 29, otherwise, we return 28. And I don't need
the else here, I'm going to put the else in just to make it look more balanced.
Okay, so now let's run our current tests, make sure we didn't break something.
They'll finished, that's a good sign. Let's add some tests that depend on leap
years. So were going to, to test the nextDay, a February 28th, if it is a leap
year. And we should do some long year tests, the number of days in a leap year
should be 366. So I've got those two, let's also add the tests that we did by
hand, and let's see, and the test all passed. And now we should try running it
on the test that were provided.